The Joe Rogan Experience you're um your
um coffee thing if you're if you're
really into it you get into the flavors
and you get into drinking it black I
used to always add cream to my coffee
and I still do if I get Starbucks
because no offense Starbucks but
generally speaking their black coffee
does not taste that good she a lot of it
is like overcooked and burnt did you I
read that Howard Schultz's um biography
and it like turned me into a huge
Starbucks fan because the guy is just so
inspirational you know he loves it he
brought Coffee Culture to America like I
mean coffee didn't exist here before
like the espresso culture and espresso
bars he just you know for whether you
like the coffee or Dawn or whatever you
say he was it's really phenomenal well
they have that one machine if you go to
that one machine that was it called a
clover yeah it like sucks the coffee
yeah what is that called yeah is that a
quote Yeah but I think Starbucks like
bottom all right yeah this is too good
yeah you know he partnered with it's
part of his book he like found this guy
that was doing this thing and he was
like I want to partner with you and
bring this to the world it's like it's a
genius piece of Kit there was a
Starbucks near my house in California
that had one and I used to always get
that I drink black but other than that I
just pour some cream in there it's good
enough but I generally like a dark roast
black coffee and I've I've gotten it's a
thing it's like you get accustomed to
the flavor and The Taste yeah that's the
machine yeah it's really wild like you
you pour the beans in there and then you
have to kind of whisk it and stir it
and there's some sort of a vacuum Pro it
is called a clover right
and there's a vacuum process that
creates the coffee and it's the perfect
temperature coffee and then you got this
weird hockey puck of grounds that come
to the top and then they just sort of
scrape that hockey look at that little
squeegee it's amazing but I so this is
my Matt and I have this conversation all
the time because I'm like you know part
of Coffee Culture at a coffee bar is the
like theater of it all yes and so when
you go to coffee but then I'm like we're
writing this cookbook I'm like dude can
we just actually make coffee and taste
it all these different ways and try and
break down what's really important like
do I gotta steep the beans and then wait
10 minutes and then start again and cut
the rest of water in there do I have to
you know is that is that is that a
blooming process really matter like how
long before I grind the beans and we
came to the conclusion that like
oh some of the things are and and and
look if you've got a morning tradition
that includes you know putting on your
monocle and like putting on your
politics
in there but but for me we were like
actually fresh grounding your beans
makes a huge difference and then I love
a pour over coffee
um
and and blooming the coffee matters like
getting it getting it wet first and then
starting and then putting a little more
water in afterwards so it has some time
sort of you know what I'm you know what
I'm talking about no explain that so
what Matt wrote the recipe in the
cookbook but basically it's like
you know a an old school glass drip
coffee maker actually makes really great
coffee like an old bun machine where
the drip comes down slow so it gets the
the the the ground coffee wet and it
gives it a chance to like absorb the
water
and then
the flavor to filter out whereas if you
just pour all the water over dry beans
right away like a French press it
doesn't well French press it Steeps it
in there right right French Press you
pour it in you let it steep in there and
then you strain it out but a lot of
people when when they do like a pour
over coffee or whatever they're doing
they just
put the beans in their filter ground
beans in the filter pour the hot water
over and let it drain through and you
leave a lot of the flavor behind whereas
if you get it wet let it sit for a
minute and then pour the rest of the
water through you have you get more
extraction of the flavor So when you say
get it wet like how wet well I put 20
percent of the water in so like for me I
do 21 grams of coffee and 350 grams of
water and that's a that's an eight very
specific well everything is this way I'm
excited about everything I do I mean
salting meat I got I do it by the by the
percentage weight everything's
percentage away from me really you don't
just like salt Bay it no no I mean I do
the Salt Bay after I weigh it first you
know
obviously
um no everything everything for me is is
is that's the way you great great
consistency and that's the way you can
really
figure out what you did wrong and get it
better is by by adjusting it
incrementally right like
so the that that 21 grams of of ground
coffee for for you know whatever it is a
full-size cup of coffee this is
beautiful but do I get to keep this one
oh yeah sure is that kind of I just
offered that no no see it yeah it's for
you thank you that would be a great
thank you I'll drink my coffee and look
every day beautiful
um I'll get weird no it's handsome
um and uh but so I take I take the first
hundred grams of water and I pour it
over and then I go and I take my my I do
some of my morning activities like I'll
before I start the shower I do like and
then I come back and I finish the coffee
the other day how much time in between
depends upon what I have for dinner the
night before really oh so you take it
take a [ __ ] and then yeah but you know
like 15 minutes yeah it could be any
amount of time it's just really it
should it'll I don't like to drink my
coffee super hot so I don't mind that
extra time to cool it down a bit but I
think you just want to give it about two
minutes for the coffee to bloom for to
for the whatever you know there are
scientists that would explain like the
starches they're absorbing the water
which is allowing them to release
because if you think about pouring
coffee over ground it's like little
ground Pebbles of coffee beans you pour
the water over and you want the water to
have a chance to Leach out the flavor
that's inside of the ground and like
espresso is really fast and you grind it
really really fine right
whereas maybe uh French Press is going
to steep for quite a while so you grind
it quite a bit coarser and so pour over
maybe somewhere in between but it still
needs a few few seconds to steep but
that's what you prefer the pour over
yeah I'm a far over guy